yeah so what it is generally what the
red pool is um i don't know if anyone
here has heard of mgtow men going their
own way does anyone have a manga in
their own way
no no no yeah you see
ladies
you don't know that men are you don't
know that men a guy in their own way i
know the concept definitely
right so the red pill community men go
in their own way it's it's basically
like you know like he said it's men that
have actually said you know what they're
a little bit jaded by the dating market
a little bit jaded by women in general
and they said you know what you know
what nah we don't need women actually
we'll just
focus on ourselves make ourselves better
and if we engage with women we do and if
we don't
we don't
so what i want to try and get is
from everyone why do you think
men
would be going their own way from women
is there a problem with women nowadays
well i wouldn't necessarily say it's a
problem with women it's kind of like
i like today's market is more like money
is more important than like
relationships so people like kind of
rising up and like going their own way
yeah i think um social media has a big
influence on that
um
and you know the rise of all the dating
apps and
there's so much choice
now for basically women and
men don't really have as many options
i would say speak into the mic a little
bit like men
generally don't really have as many
options as women so
um
they they basically decide to go their
own way focus on themselves
build up build their life their lives up
and
yeah hopefully something comes out of it
by the end of the day they're fine
they're they've got their resources set
for them and that's pretty much it
why would men begin oh wait is it
something women nowadays i think guys
are basically just taking the women's
lead because women have been doing this
for years
so that's my opinion
so women have been
going their own way for men
i feel like they have
hmm
i agree
you agree yeah
with that women have just been with that
statement of i think women have been
like you know the whole girl boss
feminism movement and like beyonce
independent women like i think the whole
stance of a woman being independent has
been out there for a little while now
i think it's refreshing that guys are
now doing it too
okay
why am i going their own way
i think
relationships are not worthwhile these
days like
yeah the
on on both sides i don't feel like
they're
good partners so if it's not going to be
good why go for it
you look like you got something on your
mind over there i'm just going to say
it's feminism in it that's what it is
explain go a little bit deeper
why why would it be what's why would
feminism make manga their own way
okay so i'm gonna have to break this
down
and okay because i know so much it's
like i would assume that everyone knows
what i know so it'll be it'll be easier
if people knew what i was talking about
but if i tried to break it down like
this
women
after like the revolution of feminism
and the burning of the bra and stuff
like that
uh
they've
they've they've allowed men to have sex
with them without
giving them a ring for it
so but then why would that make men go
their own way then exactly so because
right because i'm as a man now i don't
need to marry a woman now it's the best
man that gets the woman
so now you have the the 90 10 rule so
it's like the the best top 10 men get 90
of the single women so if i'm not if
okay i'm not gonna basically
watch my
i'm just well i'm i don't consider
myself an eye but anyway i'm not gonna
watch
a friend
get all the girls he wants
because he looks cute he looks nice so
he's doing something and then that same
girl comes back after and says oh i'm
ready for you now
it's not going to happen so that's what
as a man i'm i'm restricting myself from
that i'm i'm not going to allow it
so a lot of men angry
because of that most definitely
ladies have you have you have you seen
men become more angry nowadays
i wouldn't say more i feel like
the same i feel like yeah i think i
don't feel like there's really been
nothing that i've noticed the change
okay so people like kevin when kevin
samuel was kind of bursting to the scene
right people was he's a red pill man
yeah right and they were saying that
he's angry did you did you not see a lot
of guys
speaking the way kevin sanders was
speaking
yeah but i think they oh how we talked
about last time is like this is someone
that
that is voicing what they haven't been
able to say for a while now
but then also i think it goes back to
them not being able to successfully
get a woman
so
it's more along the lines if they can't
get it like there are a lot of in sales
yeah
is that is that is that what's going on
is there a lot of guys that just can't
get girls i mean i would say like
there's a lot of insoles pretending to
be red pill men
and that's like causing like people to
like mistake like in cells for rebel men
like some people are just angry at
females because
they're just angry at females and some
people aren't angry at females and just
want to be better
so you so you don't think like
so you haven't seen a rise in men being
angry at women
i mean like i know people who are angry
at females but it's like i don't know a
lot of them
like i can name a few and i can tell you
some of the stuff they've done
but
do you have red pool rage
[Laughter]
that's a big one
i wouldn't say i think the word the
wording is wrong i wouldn't say it's
rage
i would say it's
red pill
adapting
what does that mean
it means
like okay
i'm not i'm not
hamza from sam's chicken you know i mean
i could get a girl if i want to get a
girl do you know what i mean what does
that mean
when i say that i mean like the
invisible man i'm not the invisible man
there there's a bunch of invisible men
that walk around london right now that
women would not even stop and give like
10 seconds of the day tonight the
invisible man i'm not one of the
invisible men but i know invisible men
that's what i mean
why do you think you're not an invisible
man
um
all right it comes down to this
when i'm when i'm approaching a girl to
like
talk to her and stuff i do get the
uh f off or
leave me alone or the friends say leave
my friend alone i get that and me
because i'm like i know well enough i'm
not going to let that stop me from
stopping the next goal
but that in itself might stop a man from
speaking to another girl so you know in
effect by turning him to eff
is stopping him from finding another
goal because you are not going to go up
to the guy and
check him out are you
or you make yourself available
what is in a woman wouldn't approach a
man
in general
it it does happen but i mean in general
like it's she would more make herself
available like she'll go next to him or
she'll brush past him or she would say
hi have you got the time or like you
know like she would never just go like
i like you come what's your number do
you know me that's more you know
i think like going on